la parole est à monsieur jacques genest
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie de
l'industrie et du numérique monsieur le
ministre dans quelques heures les
chiffres du chômage pour le mois
d'octobre seront publiées bien triste
rendez vous pour les trois millions
quatre cent mille chômeurs officiels qui
savent qu'ils n'ont rien à espérer d'une
politique qui signe chaque mois son
échec à ce propos la situation d 1
million 400 mille actifs du secteur btp
est tout à fait préoccupante en un an
l'emploi salarié a baissé de 2% l'emploi
intérimaire de presque 7% et pour le
seul mois d'octobre de 20% ces chiffres
sont la conséquence d'un fait édifiant
rarement on a construit si peu de
logements en france avec seulement 300
milles mises en chantier sur les douze
derniers mois et une baisse de 11 4%
comme comme on est loin des 500 milles
promis par le candidat françois hollande
la conjecture ne peut seule expliquer ce
phénomène des normes toujours plus
nombreuses et des règles d'urbanisme
toujours plus rigide entrave la
construction notamment en milieu rural
les maires doivent faire face à
l'incompréhension de leurs concitoyens
qui voit de plus en plus de terrains
classés inconstructibles
cette situation contribue à tirer vers
le haut le prix du mètre carré de
terrain à bâtir avec une augmentation de
8 8% en 2013 et ce n'est qu'un début la
loi allure véritable usine à gaz dont
même le gouvernement reconnaît des
erreurs a enlevé toute confiance aux
investisseurs
enfin je citerai la baisse des dotations
qui affecte des collectivités
territoriales alors que ces dernières
représentent environ 70% de l'activité
les entreprises de travaux publics
aujourd'hui le gouvernement veut frapper
encore plus drastiquement et brutalement
leurs ressources en dépit du compromis
équilibré trouvé par le cdh à des
quelques avancées présentées dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2015
n'auront que des effets très différer
dans le temps et ne suffiront pas à mme
c'est le redémarrage indispensable pour
ce secteur qui est l'un des piliers de
notre croissance et qui créent des
emplois qui ne sont pas délocalisables
car monsieur le ministre allez-vous
prendre des mesures urgentes qui
s'imposent pour faire repartir
l'activité et d'emplois dans la
construction
merci mon chat room collègues la parole
est à madame carole delga secrétaire
d'état chargé du commerce de l'artisanat
de la consommation et de l'économie
sociale et solidaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jacques genest la
crise du logement pèse lourdement sur le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens qui
dépensent en comparaison de la plupart
de nos voisins européens beaucoup trop
pour se loger dans de nombreuses villes
il est difficile de trouver un logement
aujourd'hui l'urgence dans ce pays et de
donner un logement à tous les français
quelle que soit leur situation quelles
que soient leurs besoins pour y parvenir
nous n'avons d'autre choix que de
construire davantage car les problèmes
du mal-logement proviennent
essentiellement d'un manque de
construction nous avons donc agi pour la
relance de la construction notamment en
fluidifiant les parcours résidentiels
les entreprises du bâtiment nous ont
fait part bien sûr je les reçois des
difficultés considérables et nous avons
mis en place un certain nombre de
mesures nous devons en effet poursuivre
cet objectif gouvernemental qui est
d'avoir un impact important pour la
croissance n'aime pas positif sur
l'emploi nous avons simplifié les règles
en matière d'urbanisme encourager
l'investissement
restaurer la confiance pour relancer la
construction et permettre aux ménages
d'accéder au logement
je n'oublie pas non plus les efforts de
rénovation de logements car dans la
rénovation des logements il y a un
impact plus rapide que la construction
du neuf que nous avons menées avec le
crédit d'impôt développement durable
relevé à 30 % avec bien sûr le
renforcement de l'éco prêt de ptz voilà
anciens avec également les aides de
l'anah notre principale priorité est
bien de redonner un élan à cette machine
qui est bloquée et qui est responsable
d'une pénurie dans les zones tendues
notamment de logements adaptés je pense
également au logement intermédiaire que
nous avons assoupli et encore améliorer
ce plan pour le logement bénéficiera
donc à tous les français et c'est la
raison pour laquelle des mesures sont
déjà en place le dispositif
d'investissement locatif peut
s'appliquer sur 6 9 ou 12 ans pour
s'adapter aux horizons d'investissement
des ménages l'abattement exceptionnel de
30% pour inciter à la libération de
foncier la réforme du ptz et du zonage
pour les adapter aux réalités du marché
immobilier et d'autres mesures
s'appliqueront dès que le projet de loi
de finances pour 2015 sera votée merci
madame la ministre